dandaka GSB and college basketball
analyst host of the dandaka show on 1070
the fan in Indianapolis he called a lot
of the summer league games in Las Vegas
we want to get on the Memphis Grizzlies
bandwagon and print up some t-shirts
what do you think 65 225 I've lost 20
pounds
yeah man you got to do it anytime you
can win the summer league I think that
that immediate immediately goes to
national media gentleman on bandwagons
t-shirts and ticket sales don't forget
ticket sales I'm guessing skyrocketed
for the week but hey Brandon Clark was
really good they played as a team
Grayson Allen calm down a little bit and
get tossed after the one game that we
did and uh it is a great time damn
you've been out there it's fantastic I
have not but the last couple of years
the last three years I have watched more
summer league basketball than maybe I've
watched regular season basketball for
some reason you know we we look at teams
and going into these seasons we've said
all it's Golden State winning the title
but I sort of wanted to see how these
two teams can dream and you see some of
these younger players but I just don't
know what the proper summer league
reaction should be like what is the real
takeaway from the summer league this
year in your opinion I don't well a
couple things I think number one the
interest in the NBA in the summer
I mean look Danny I was asking this
question of NBA guys guys that actually
make money in the NBA do you think this
summer is more interesting than the
regular season after Christmas you know
cuz at Christmas we all watch the games
because we're doing nothing we're eating
we're watching and then you fall into it
in January February now okay and then
the playoffs are great but Dan they all
told me the same thing man they said
look yeah summer's more interesting
because of the free agency because of
unlike other sports Big D big-time free
agents move and shift the balance of the
league and with maybe another sport I
guess maybe an ace ball does that to a
to a little bit but you're not alone Dan
I swear to God I never watched the
summer league until the last couple
years never and and getting a chance Dan
the other thing those crowds were
unbelievable
there's a lot of stuff to do in Vegas
there is you can find you can find stuff
at 10:00 in the morning 11:00 12:00 all
the way you know and people came to
summer league it was great it really was
best fantastic best young players you
saw that you think will have an impact
during the regular season Jackson Hayes
is interesting the kid from Cincinnati I
talked to a bunch of Cincinnati high
school coaches at two years coached
against him and didn't think all that
much of them amazing Dan I'm not sure
I've ever seen and I'm I guess maybe
I'll go back to Moses Malone a kid that
goes after everything on the backboard I
mean everything like he goes up and he
goes again if if you know that rule they
have in Europe where you can go tend to
shot you know you can bask you to
interfere it's not illegal if they had
that in the NBA I swear to god the kid
with averaged 20 his first year because
he I've never seen like it I really have
it
Lonnie Walker the fourth who was hurt
last year I was going to play for San
Antonio and the problem for San Antonio
Big D is that well San Antonio is in the
same side with Houston who has two stars
to LA teams that are great Golden State
so we met we talked about San Antonio
I'm telling you man Lonnie Walker he's
pretty damn good and Brandon Clark was
the MVP is a he's not quite Leonard but
he's that type of player guard a bunch
of spots athletic gonna have to shoot it
and quiet had to shoot it coming out but
the talent was really really good it was
it was fans action Hayes just I just
marveled at him and I do think what he
does translate to the regular season
because his energy is just off the
charts
why wasn't John Moran playing I don't
know nobody would tell me you know well
he's just not playing okay well I asked
why is he not playing well you know he
just not okay you know they all tried to
say that like he didn't play tide Jerome
didn't play when is this load management
all ready for John ranted about the
contract and trades and it was okay
everything went back to Anthony Davis
like the Anthony Davis deal didn't get
done so Memphis couldn't play John
Wright I don't know I honestly don't and
and truth is dance
you know and somebody like somebody can
tell you on the phone something but when
you're looking at them and they tell you
the same thing you can tell whether
their BS and you or not you don't I mean
and that's all I got was like fifteen
different answers and none of them seem
real well unless it was because he had a
minor knee procedure so that was right
after the draft so that's the only thing
I thought of is you know maybe he they
just don't know I mean there's no reason
to put him out there it's like Zion
Williamson should he have been out there
in the first place whether he's in shape
enough well I mean depends on what
you're trying to do I mean if you're
trying to see you know different things
from him then if he's in shaped and yes
but if you know he's not in shape no way
do you put him out there not a chance
and and if it is John Moran's deal then
absolutely not a chance I mean you just
can't do that who cares I mean then
let's be honest I mean I don't know
seems to me like if Durant and klay
Thompson don't both get hurt the Golden
State's gonna win the title there's no
sense in risking anybody in the summer
league I mean and again but like if you
want to see if design Williamson can
bring the ball down and play a point
guard or a five against you know certain
teams and maybe but not if he's not in
shape and he was clearly not in shape
what are the Act what what are
reasonable expectations for Zion
Williamson this year oh man I think he
know I've said this before I think he's
the smartest player coming in the
professional basketball this year and
he's over talented which we know I think
reasonable expectations based on the way
the NBA goes is that he has great
numbers and I'm talking like 18 and 9 or
18 and 10 or something like that I just
think that's the way the NBA is set up
it's set up four stars when you're the
star of your team and I think that the
NBA rules put itself where you can score
I mean if you conduce things with the
basketball and he can you can score
people are gonna be people are gonna be
disappointed at 18 and 9 then I don't
think so not as a rookie I wouldn't be I
I I'm taking the under I'm
I'm very cautious with this because I've
seen guys go into the league and you go
boy he can't miss and all of a sudden
you go away what's happening here and I
also think he's such a great team player
that I think I think just like he did it
Duke he wants everybody to enjoy what
he's enjoying and I think that that's I
think he'll really be conscious of that
I don't think it RJ Barrett's gonna put
up more numbers I think than Zion
because that's his mindset and he's
playing for the Knicks Zion to me is a
you know a lot more team oriented and I
if you gave me 18 and 9 for Zion I would
say I love it but I think people be
disappointed in that what people can be
but then it comes down to do they win
and do they win with him
see Dan the reason I went 18 and 9 is
because of exactly what you said my but
my initial inkling is okay about 20 22
24 then I thought about exactly what you
said and he's a team guy he'll pass the
ball hey look you know when LeBron James
came into the league and everybody got
mad I remember against Detroit the
playoffs he drove it kicked it to
Danielle marshal here's a corner shooter
you know you make the right play
sometimes in the NBA you get criticized
right because you're not trying to
dominate you're not trying to score tie
things I'm Winston is a right play kind
of guy but I also think this now again
Dan let me ask you this over/under 82
games how many does Zion Williams in
play assuming he's healthy huh assuming
he's healthy like there I'm saying I'm
saying if does he get hurt
oh okay they hit him you know I'm saying
I'm saying like right now he's about
everybody told me about 15 pounds
overweight all right let's just assume
he starts the season healthy okay how
many games do you think he plays 80
games no do you think he plays 70 games
I'll say 72 games that's kind of where I
was like it's 73 I think he's missed 10
yeah you know I mean yeah now that now
that maybe they load managing maybe he
gets hurt I don't know but I do think
this I think two things with Diane
Williamson I think number one he's got
to get in great shape and I think that's
hard
for a kid his age I just do it number
two he's got to shoot the basketball he
just you know he's not Ben Simmons where
he makes others better driving the ball
as the point guy that kind of stuff but
he's gonna have to shoot the basketball
and then I was go to this and maybe I've
said this on your show and I love
Calbert Cheaney my favorite player ever
to coach but when he came out of college
that three-point line in the NBA the
difference was too deep for him yes it's
it's it's too deep for most humans you
know when you go out of this college 3
is not a big deal you move out a couple
feet you're going only smokes this is a
long way you know you were talking about
Ben Simmons how do you how do you not
have the the workings the makings that
like something I can build on with his
shot that he finishes everything with
his right hand but he shoots his
so-called jumper with his left hand like
I I don't get this I don't get it
it's the stiffest arm action I've ever
seen I did a couple of his games at LSU
and people got mad at me because I said
you know this might be the only guy that
I've ever watched that's a good player
you know like that's a really good
player that will never be able to shoot
the basketball like magic couldn't shoot
coming out but you could see his elbow
was under the ball didn't really think
it was important this dude has the
stiffest shoulder to fingertip and I
endless it's like you know that Supreme
Court justice say about point I can't
define it but I know what what I see
it's the same is the same thing with Ben
Simmons I can't define it but I know it
when I see it it's just so stiff that
Danny it's it I maybe when he's seven
years into the league you know he'll
figure it out but I don't see it anytime
soon I really don't yeah but I don't you
talked about magic and I brought up
magic too because magic at least had the
workings of a form and he Ben doesn't
have form you know I can help you know
if you say let me see your shot okay I
tuck the arm you know elbow in a little
bit more here get a little bit tighter
here don't be so loose with you know
whatever
use your legs a little bit more with him
I wouldn't
where to start dan the one thing I know
in basketball is how to teach shooting I
mean I that so one thing I know I mean
but and I swear to God
it's the same thing usually I can see
out if he would just get his shoulders a
little bit out in front of his feet you
know if he would just step in more if he
would just keep his elbow on there he
needs wrist action off the big three
fingers that kind of thing but I'm
telling you you I swear to god he's the
only guy Dan I've ever seen you could
teach him that and I and it's just so
stiff I'm trying to think what I would
what I is like Charles Barkley's golf
swing it's like all right where do you
start with all of this and no matter
what you do it's going to end up poorly
you just I think you just hope that
repetition becomes muscle memory becomes
efficient shot I just but I'm telling
you you're so right there is eight just
I don't know start underwater I do some
but you know Lonzo ball all of a sudden
has a good looking jumper after I watch
Ben Simmons yeah all these Rick mount
for crying out loud no ball yeah you
know I mean that's Indiana reference
you're back in the day but that's
alright you got it
because you're a shooter you're a ball
yeah yeah videos would you rather have
Ben Simmons or Jo Ellen beat I want Jo
Ellen big man I want Jo MB to stop being
a Twitter funny guy
I want Jo lb to get in great shape and I
want to go in championships with Jo LMB
die I want Joel embiid to sit down with
like the mean guys of the league like
sit down with magic and bird being
serious Isaiah being serious and have
them have a serious discussion on being
an absolute killer as a basketball
player and I want Joel embiid like cut
ripped and I think he could be the best
player on the planet I just think that
all that silly stuff gets in the way
would you rather have Anthony Davis to
the Greek freak
and I would have said before like
Christmas artisan Anthony Davis but man
I like me some Greek freak I Greek freak
to me is the only guy that I've seen
that teams play off of him with great
athletic guys and he still drives and
dunks over them honest to god I love
Anthony Davis I'd like to have both but
I'm kind of sold on the Greek freak
right now I'm like see Anthony Davis
healthy for a year and playing with
LeBron that may change you know in six
months but right now it gave me the
Greek Creek great stuff with the summer
link I really enjoyed the broadcast
I thought you guys had some good
chemistry and it was fun to listen to
appreciate the techs big day appreciate
you guys having me I'm Dan dockage ESPN
college basketball analyst former
college coach condoms hire coaches
corner proud supported the Dan Patrick
show Continental Tire is and dandaka
jizz as well for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]